hello this is Len Goldman and I'm here
to talk about this flu season in 2019
and how we can protect our own health
and the health of members of our family
so it's important to recognize what is
flu and the fact that every illness that
we have in winter is not flu in fact
most of them are common colds but flu is
an acute illness meaning that it comes
on suddenly and it doesn't last very
long and it results from an infection by
an influenza virus flu as you all know
is highly infectious spreads very
rapidly from one person to the next and
there are different strains of flu some
of which cause illnesses that are much
more severe than others it's important
to recognize the symptoms of flu because
that is one of the primary ways we
protect people is by recognizing that we
may have the flu and flu is generally of
sudden onset you've got a fever headache
aching muscles severe weakness as well
as a respiratory symptoms like cough
sore throat and difficulty breathing and
so it's a little bit more than just like
a cold like illness in that you do have
usually that headache and those muscle
pains as well as a fever incubation
period how long does it take to develop
the flu after you're exposed to it the
range is anywhere between one and four
days for most flu viruses between two
and three days that unfortunately does
mean that you can be infected and then
nonetheless be spreading the flu without
being sick so influenza it's spreading
from one person to the next and we need
to be in pretty close proximity to
another person in order to get the virus
unfortunately though it spreads to
coughing and sneezing there are droplets
that are broadcast into the air when we
Contra sneeze and actually they're quite
a number of them and they go quite a
long distance in a space and when you
breathe in those droplets you can become
infected by the flu virus they also can
be spread through directly
touching an infected person or
unfortunately a surface that's
contaminated with the virus such as
surfaces to become contaminated when
they're sneezing or coughing by somebody
with the flu flu has its of ancient
origin we've known about it for a long
time
412 BC it was mentioned by Hippocrates
and they first salute pandemic
description that we know of was in 1580
and since that time we've had a number
of them they they cycle with
unpredictable numbers of years some
intervals between them unfortunately we
have no way of really predicting when
we're going to have a major flu outbreak
there are three types of flu that are
really important for people the type A
which can also not only be hosted by
people but also Birds pick some horses
type B which is a human disease and type
C and we classify the influenza virus on
the basis of small protein molecules
that are on the surface of the virus and
without going into technical detail
about these molecules but some of them
are called
H markers H stands for hemagglutinin and
there 15 of those that were aware of in
nature and others are called n markers
or neuraminidase markers but these
markers aren't just to help us to
identify which bug we have they also
have the enhance the ability of the
virus to either attach to people or to
replicate and so they can also be
signals of how bad that flu is going to
be on the basis of it being able to
infect a person or to replicate itself
so when we talk about flu we talk about
these two concepts of epidemics and
pandemics epidemics are serious
outbreaks that occur in a community or a
population and actually every winter we
have a flu epidemic but pandemics are
much more major outbreaks that spread
around the world affect hundreds of
thousands of people across many
countries
therefore far more serious seasonal flu
then is kind of an annual and
predictable epidemic and last year we
had a particularly interesting flu year
because it was the longest flu season
ever 21 weeks in length that was because
we actually had a double hitter we had
two epidemics one by virus called an
h1n1 and then a second by a virus called
an h3 m3 that most of us perceived as
just a very long epidemic of flu but it
had consequences in terms of how we
could get vaccines and how we can
protect ourselves
now for this coming year the outlook is
it's still a little hazy but this is
what the experts think they most likely
our epidemic will occur between October
and the beginning of April which is the
the normal three flu season not a long
one like 2018 and most likely that we'll
see a peak in February and what we've
been preparing for under the guidance of
the World Health Organization or who and
the CDC is for flu viruses the h1n1 the
h5 n2 and to influenza B viruses when
you package these four viruses into one
vaccine we call that vaccine tetravalent
so if you hear that term tetravalent
that's what that means for viruses so
getting the flu vaccine hopefully by the
end of November is the single most
important step that you can take and
unfortunately you have to do that every
single year the components that are in
the vaccine for 2018 won't protect you
from the flu that will be circulating in
2019 and because the flus shift every
year and also because the immunity is
actually not very long-lasting need to
get the flu vaccine annually but the
good news is that the vaccine that's
tetravalent that covers all four of the
circulating viruses in 2019
it's available in all its forms and so
we have a form called FluMist which is a
nasal spray which is available for
people between the ages of two and
forty-nine not for children under the
age of two and not for older people
people fifty and older for whom and
hasn't been tested but still most people
theoretically could get the the nasal
spray and that is a very convenient way
to receive the vaccine injectable
vaccines that are widely available
including versions that are egg free and
if you suspect or know that you have an
egg allergy you need to be sure to let
your vaccine provider know that so they
can give you the egg free version and
then special forms that are either
higher dose or contain something called
an adjuvant that boosts the immunity are
recommended for people who are over the
age of 65 and that's because as we age
our immune systems don't respond as
vigorously to a vaccine and we want to
especially make sure that the older
population is protected the bad news is
that not all vaccine forms are yet
available in sufficient quantities I'm
speaking to you now in mid-october there
is a lot of effort to produce those I
had a personal experience this week
going out to get my vaccine which I was
able to get I get a little bandaid on my
shoulder here but the first two places
that I went for my vaccine they had run
out of the high dose version for people
over the age of 65 and I understand that
those companies that manufacture those
vaccines have ramped a manufacturer
they're sure they're going to have
enough by the end of November but I
would recommend that you call ahead and
make sure that whichever one you need or
your family members need according to
their age that those will be available
when you go to get it so who needs the
flu vaccine well I think I've already
said everybody nearly everybody needs to
receive the vaccine except for
infants under the age of six months and
but that especially younger kids kids
between the age of six months and 59
months and older people people over the
age of fifty years are the highest risk
Rafi flu also people with certain
chronic health problems like cardiac
disease respiratory disease hiv/aids
virus
diabetes and obesity are at higher risk
and so although we try to get everybody
to go in and get a vaccine we also do
try to focus on making absolutely
certain that the highest risk people are
getting them others that are very high
priority for vaccine are healthcare
personnel caregivers household contacts
of young infants children and people
with high-risk medical conditions
pregnant women as I said before people
with AIDS but also others who are
immunosuppressed for any reasons such as
people who have received a transplant
however again infants under the age of
six months should not receive the
vaccine and again people with egg
allergies need to talk to a healthcare
provider because there are egg free
vaccines available and you don't want to
have an allergic reaction to your flu
vaccine anyone with a history of
guillain-barre syndrome or GBS I think
you know it if you've had it it's a very
severe disease it causes paralysis but
you need to talk to your medical
provider because if that's to be sent
then you wouldn't be qualified I could
take the vaccine so turning to the topic
of pandemic though so as I mentioned
before a pandemic is a global epidemic
and it happens when there is a newly
emerged strain of flu usually a new
influenza a subtype so we know that in
in the last year which flu strains have
been circulating across the planet and
which ones were expecting to come here
but a pandemic could be caused by one
that hasn't already been circulating
and we've actually had for the size of
three four pandemics in the last century
the worst of which killed 20 to 40
million people worldwide in fact these
are the four that that we're aware of
this so-called Spanish flu that was
actually a hundred years ago nineteen
eighteen and nineteen killed twenty to
forty million people the Asian flu that
happened in the late 50s killed about a
million people the Hong Kong flu
that wasn't even ten years after the the
Asian flu killed another million and
then the h1n1 epidemic and you can see
actually there were forty years in
between the Hong Kong flu and h1n1 which
killed 200,000 people and so I think you
can see from this table that we really
don't have a regular cycle of how
frequently these pandemics come along
and it does appear to me that it's
possible that we're doing better over
time with reducing the numbers of death
globally from these pandemics so again a
pandemic is caused by a new flu virus
and this new virus is easily passing
from person to person because basically
no one has any immunity they haven't
been vaccinated it's a novel virus we
don't have immunity from from former
years and so it spreads very widely and
it causes more serious illness there are
things about the world that have made
pandemics scarier we have a much larger
population something we've changed over
two centuries from less than a billion
to six to seven billion people we have
intercontinental travel that occurs over
the space of hours rather than months
millions of people are traveling rather
than hundreds we have crowding we've
improved our population health but we've
changed how we deal with animals and
some of these novel viruses come from
our barn animals our chickens are pigs
and those viruses in those animals
combining with human ones and our
dependence on other other countries has
increased and which means that we need
to have more commerce across the world
so the opportunities for virus emergence
and spread are definitely there the you
know modern production of pigs and
poultry the proximity of people to those
but just the crowding that we have and
the amount of travel that we have that
allows for virus spread if I caught four
sneeze and there's just one person in
the room there's less likely first
spread than if there were hundred people
in the room so everyone is at risk if
there's a pandemic but some risks are
too great a risk of serious some groups
at a greater risk of serious illness
than others
telomerase starts circulating we don't
really know for sure who is at most risk
for example in a normal flu epidemic
it's the youngest and the oldest and the
population who are at highest risk but
the h1n1 was particularly risky for
young adults adolescents and young
adults and that's something we couldn't
have predicted before we were actually
in the middle of the pandemic so we have
a lot of lessons from past pandemics the
unpredictability not even always in
winter the h1n1 started in summer a lot
of variability and the mortality how bad
is the virus and how severe is the
illness and what is the pattern of the
ages that are most severely affected
rabbit surge in the cases over brief
periods of time and occurring in waves
but the key thing is that these tend to
be unpredictable so we can define
different stages and I think these are
important one the first stage and we've
done a lot of work to to be a more
effective with this stage globally
identifying and investigating cases of
novel virus getting in there early makes
a difference training health workers to
recognize when a novel virus has a
potential be transmitted from one person
to another being able to see the
initiation of the first pandemic wave
which women accelerate and then many
people are infected and then decelerate
as the wave goes down and then we have
to prepare for a future waves because
some of these pandemics have second
waves that can be worse than the first
so there is no vaccine that's waiting in
a freezer somewhere to distribute if
there's a pandemic because you first
have to identify the specific virus you
can't predict it ahead of time and the
ordinary ordinary flu vaccine or some
pass vaccine will not provide protection
so what can we do one thing is that we
try to interdict the transmission at the
earliest possible time find those first
few cases quarantine them prevent that
first way from even happening and if we
start to see acceleration of
transmission then there might be actions
that are very difficult for society to
take which we saw with h1n1 minute even
would remember that we were closing
schools and daycare centers trying to
promote social distancing so we wouldn't
be sneezing on each other and touching
each other
decreasing unnecessary travel and when
needed
using antiviral drugs as prescribed of
course by physicians so my parting
message what do we do now
first and foremost get the flu vaccine
unless you're one of the rare
individuals that has an exception a
reason why you can't have the vaccine or
of course a young infant but the second
thing is to be prepared for flu
understanding the symptoms is very
important and then if you recognize you
may have the symptoms to not go to work
or school and you try to avoid
transmission to others especially those
who are at most risk that's often our
loved ones family members who are young
infants family members who are elderly
you do not want to be the person who
spread the flu to those individuals so
thanks so much for listening today and I
hope that you feel dolly prepared
truthfully
season but to talk to others patients
members of your community got how to do
that thank you
[Music]